hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's time to look back at season for a
fortnight Battle Royale and uncover
those Easter eggs those references to
pop culture a handful of memes and now
fortnight has an underpinning story so
we'll take a look back at that - season
4 kicked off on May the 1st 2018 running
until July the 12th and followed on from
season three with the meteor hurling
toward the island it hit and that's
where season four kicks off the world
will never be the same the new season
gives us a cinematic superhero theme
brace for impact like always we'll start
with the battle pass and for season four
we received upgradeable characters with
modular add-ons the Carbide and omega in
their natural forms they resemble the
antihero spawn from Image Comics
but as carbide upgrades with additional
armor he takes inspiration from Marvel's
Ironman and his ever evolving suit
whereas a mega upgraded skin takes on
the look of a cyborg ninja like Kenji
from overwatch or grey fox a trident
from Metal Gear Solid all the characters
on the battle path include Zoe complete
with her sweet tooth set if you've seen
wreck-it Ralph you may see the
similarities to the little candlehead
girl and the candy filled world Ralph
finds himself in a guy with glasses well
played the technique skin looks to be a
graffiti artist and once again borrows
from another superhero Alton jet set
radio on the Sega Dreamcast from all the
way back in 2000 not all superheroes
wear capes remember the valour skin
unlocked at tier 71 includes inspiration
from Diana Prince
aka Wonder Woman the iconic red and blue
color scheme from the original design
complete with tiara combined with the
Amazonian style from the Justice League
films there's also two more skins in the
battle bus the squad leader and a battle
hawk let's start with the squad leader I
think this is a Hawkeye reference from
the first Thor film the armor matches up
almost perfectly but notice the single
sleeve used by many archers to prevent
snagging it's a bit tenuous that one but
I have more proof Oh before I move on
though
the squad leader also has a spider on
his uniform which is mighty close to the
spider-man logo yet another Marvel hero
at a push battle Hawk looks to be based
on Thor and spoiler alert his lost eye
in Ragnarok and his short haircut for
that role when he dons the Lightning sky
trails the similarities are uncanny
and that would also explain all the
luggage with his tag on it the meteor
from season 3 we were all expecting to
hit tilted towers actually smashed down
over dusty Depot creating dusty divot
other areas of the map were hit by
debris but not to the same extent this
is also where we found a new mechanic in
fortnight jumped rocks which allowed us
to take jumping around like rabbits to
another level but I'm getting
sidetracked back to dusty divot once the
meteor landed a makeshift government
facility was erected around it which is
almost identical to that found in the
first Thor film when his hammer created
a dusty divot of its own the tubes
connecting buildings were spot on the
same leading many to believe Thor's
hammer may be inside the meteor it
wasn't but we'll get to that very soon
the way the meteor was introduced is
shot in a way to mimic b-movies and in
particular it came from outer space
which has a very similar story actor
season 4 informant
[Music]
yes it came from outer space to fill the
world with terror to bring you
unforgettable suspense what was it
around the map new locations could be
found
in addition to all the potholes a
mansion sprung up overnight sneer lonely
Lodge which looked mighty familiar could
this before tonight's version of Bruce
Wayne's or Tony Stark's mansion on
further inspection although it's not as
grand as a Bruce Wayne's mansion it does
have its own little Batcave
there's even tech being developed in a
room under a secret passage which could
be the carbide skin or maybe the flash
if this was a superhero bunker then
chances are the super villains were very
close by in fact on the mountain
overlooking snobby jaws was a
supervillain base carved into the rock
face that face on the rock takes
inspiration from Castle Grayskull from
the Masters of the Universe TV show
which I'm embarrassed to say I
completely remember it could also be a
nod to scho island from king kong other
supervillains have mountain bases too
but the most iconic is Blofeld's volcano
lair from the 5th James Bond film You
Only Live Twice he had a retractable
roof to keep his Rockets under cover
for tonight super villains don't have
the same luxuries other new additions to
the map include a similar superhero
bunker found under the house in salty
springs this one looks to be inspired by
spider-man and his hidden basement in
the spider-man comic books used to keep
his identity safe and to keep his Aunt
May out of danger
speaking of basements there's a few
twitch streamers and YouTube setups
found around the world complete with
green screens these were actually added
so content creators in game could use
them as backdrops I thought it's a
pretty cool idea
another new location was created and
destroyed immediately this is risky
reals a drive-in theater what's really
cool about this place is the film sign
outside each week the movies changed
here's all the ones that I caught cow
buyed Returns is taken from Superman
Returns from 2006 valor origins is a nod
to the x-men origin series including the
brilliantly terrible Wolverine Origins
omegas revenge looks to be from Star
Wars Episode three Revenge of the Sith
dusty impact links the happenings at
dusty divet and the plot of deep impact
a film about a meteor wipe
humanity the hills are haunted is a nod
to the hills have eyes a horror film
from 1977 which was remade in 2006 and
you must know this one the cabin in the
wailing woods yeah it's a reference to
the brilliant cabin in the woods from
2012 which is one of the greatest
self-aware horror films ever created
oh and thousand it - well well Chris
Hemsworth is not the real god of thunder
revenge of bryce dog part 2 is another
nod to Star Wars but it also looks like
it's an in-joke for epic employees it
came from moisty maya is derived from it
came from outer space from 1953 and
during the World Cup the film titles
were replaced with sports based movies
such as the beautiful game which is a
nickname for football or soccer there's
quite a few more of these but you get
the idea let's move on up in the north
of the map is a new soundstage built
which looks like it's recording a sitcom
many people believe this is the same set
as that seventies show with the couch
chair and stairs have been in the same
place other sitcoms have also used this
setup in the past such as The Fresh
Prince of bel-air and The Cosby Show but
I'm not sure if we're allowed to talk
about The Cosby Show anymore I'm sorry
YouTube Oberyn wailing woods
a mysterious bunker appeared from
nowhere as I'm writing this I'm still
unsure if it has any purpose but during
season four it became known as the lost
hatch in reference to the TV show Lost
let's set the scene following a plane
crash on a strange Island the survivors
find this hatch and for months we are
trying to figure out what's inside I
won't tell you what is inside on the TV
show because that would be a spoiler but
if you haven't watched it I recommend
lost well the first two years anyway it
gets it gets really far-fetched after
that I'm getting sidetracked again
aren't I
moist amaya also received an overhaul in
season four with a film crew moving in
to shoot a superhero movie the
green-screen helicopter crash is all set
up ready to film and shares a striking
resemblance to a horrific film scene
shot in 1982 for a film called The
Twilight Zone which cost three actors
their lives but of course that must be a
coincidence and the scene being shot
will most likely be another nod to it
came from outer space going back to the
battle pass again let's look at some of
the emotes we can unlock just before
season 4 began epic letters all danced
for a chance to be in
at night one child known as the orange
shirt kid put forward this epic dance
move lo and behold it was added to the
game as orange justice the dance itself
looked to have been created by a chap
named Roy Purdy who can't stop dancing
in every aspect of his life the popcorn
emote is likely taken from Deadpool's
antics and his inability to actually get
any in his mouth
due to the mask he wears the groove Jam
is taken perfectly from the film
Napoleon Dynamite and the moves we all
wish we were cool enough to pull off the
hype dance is a little harder to find
the roots off it looks to have started
life in the shoots video by block boy in
July 2017 but my favorite version is
this gentleman who is probably the
greatest sorcerer in history season four
gave us a story to follow each week
after completing our challenges a new
load screen gave us a little bit more
information every 7 days oh and it also
had a hidden battle star to collect - if
you were able to complete seven weeks of
the challenge a new skin called
blockbuster would become unlocked and
playable here's my take on the story
season 4 told us in Ultra QuickTime as
the movie crew were filming a scene for
it came from moisty Maya something
crash-landed into the prison nearby it
was revealed that Omega evil landed via
meteor or found himself freed by the
explosion
our heroes discovered his secret base in
the mountains and began to formulate a
plan in his lair Omega began to build an
army of augmenta soldiers to do battle
which took place in tilted towers it was
then revealed to be part of the movie as
the actors were seen socializing on set
ultimately the film was cashing in on
the meteor hitting dusty deppoh little
did they know that the meteor did indeed
have an alien on board who broke out of
dusty divot he used the supervillain
lair to prepare the rocket to launch
using the hot rocks being retrieved by
the government then came the day he
chose to launch broadcasting the signal
to all TVs in the vicinity either
warning the innocent or preparing them
for annihilation was he here to conquer
us or was he trying to get back home
what happened next
only happened a single time and could
not be repeated he is
went down
the visitor somehow managed to create
ruptures in time and rifts between
dimensions although it looked like
tilted towers was about to be destroyed
a malfunction caused the rocket to warp
around the map the rift left behind
began to eat away at the four night
world with nom noms the tomato head and
the derp burger being ripped from this
reality and vanishing overnight but then
something even stranger happened items
from other worlds began to drop through
the rifts in time a stagecoach was found
above moisty Maya a skeleton of a huge
animal or maybe a dinosaur or spotted in
moisty Maya and a huge anchor was
spotted between snobby shores and greasy
Grove which look ancient in design
perhaps Roman perhaps nas something was
definitely happening here
of course you'll already know what
happened next but in the last day of
season 4 we are expecting the theme of
time travel to be revealed in season 5
and maybe we'll know what happened to
the tomato head the derp burger and nom
noms as an update to this during the
final days of season 4 elements within
the game were found in the real world
such as llamas around Europe and the
derp burger actually appeared in the
desert an individual monitoring that
burger was handing out these cards with
a phone number upon calling that number
would hear the sound of the rift then
some clever people use spectrograms
whatever the heck they are and found
this hidden message which converted into
ASCII read as c7 the coordinates the
derp burger vanished wrong also there's
the face from the supervillain mountain
here pretty cool season 4 introduced
many cool elements such as spray-paint
shopping carts and hidden battle puss
tears in the loading screens but let's
go back to that blockbuster skin which
is now called the visitor does he look
familiar to you well judging by his
attire he's based on Bubba or Jango
Fett's he was an intergalactic bounty
hunter with very similar apparel but he
didn't have LEDs in his face his
backpack has elements of the proton
packs used by the Ghostbusters in both
film and TV I also see another superhero
from my childhood in this design The
Rocketeer from 1991 but I honestly
expect that skin to arrive sometime in
the future a cool little update to the
map can be found on the west near greasy
Grove this Shack somehow has been
smashed
is seemingly for a movie scene if we
look at this from above we can see it's
actually a footprint from a gigantic
being maybe a dinosaur could it be
Godzilla hopefully we'll find out next
season something a little weird would
also happen during season 4 when
entering a toilet take a look the stalls
would color-coordinate for male or
female queue because how strange is that
this kept us entertained for hours by
the way simple things for simple - the
fork knife mean depicting a young lady
trying to impress her boyfriend by plain
pot Knight has found its way into season
4 by this mobile kitchen there's a
loading screen which mimics Jurassic
Park and the kitchen scene where the
kids use a reflection to outsmart a few
velociraptors the bring it emote is a
not soft subtle nod to Dwayne Johnson
and his the rock persona from back in
his WWE run to finish let's go through
some of the stock in the item shop over
season 4 the rules here are simple I can
only use items that were released within
the confines of season 4 so I can't talk
about the skull trooper from season 1
being based on the Karate Kid movie from
1984 I totally forgot to put that in
during season 1 so I thought I'd slip in
now and no one would notice am i right
the boneless emote looks to be a nod to
Conor McGregor and his boxing antics
against Floyd Mayweather but I think
it's a reference to Nathan Barnett and
his boneless dance from back in 2011 the
chicken emote is taken from Arrested
Development a us situation comedy one
day we may see the banana stamp to the
roar emote designed for the dinosaur
skins in the game looks to be taken from
this viral video
let's tell them this chap has the star
power remote is a reference to kpop and
see popinjay poplin whatever letter of a
country want to put before the word pop
and in particular these dance moves from
the lovelyz and they're tuned at sure i
feel really uncomfortable watching this
i feel like i'm going to be arrested can
we move on thank you
the zany emot-- looks somewhat loosely
based on this dance performed by a green
alien in the official music video for el
Chapo's 1998 song damage to casita
damage to casita damn food I don't speak
other languages this is why dumb aa2
casita brand-spanking-new Detective
skins were introduced in the last few
days of season 4 and they looked
familiar to me as each of the spies had
a wanted poster in their pockets for the
other one one had a black coat one had a
white coat this must be a nod to the
video game Spy vs spy in which a white
and black spy go head to head
celebrating Morocco's birthday on the
4th of July was this eagle emote again
it looked familiar to me so I looked
into it ever heard of Eddie the Eagle
Edwards he's a British Olympian who
decided to take up ski jumping and set a
UK record in 1988 at the time he was
seen as a comedy act
as he always finished last and to
celebrate not dying from every jump he
would do this afterwards the eagle
the rambunctious is another dance
inspired by The Fresh Prince of bel-air
in particular it's this scene with Will
Smith throwing some shapes while jazzy
jeff drums I know I've said this before
but the nannies were so bloody great and
finally the greatest superhero crossover
imaginable in 2018 fan outs the ultra
villain from The Avengers
popped up in fortnight with his own game
modes his famous Infinity Gauntlet click
is here too
by the way look at this for perfect
timing of that bloody magic so there we
have a ridiculous amount of Easter eggs
memes cultural references and the story
we've lived through in season four like
always I'll be back again when season
five comes to an end if you missed our
previous episodes I'll link them now and
if I've missed anything please let me
know in the comments
oh we did it that was the longest edit
of my life it's been a pleasure my
name's Adam from PlayStation granade
I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]